there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea it comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the King died that was
last night
[Music]
I just want to say a quick thanks to my
cast and crew it's been a great sheet
and Thank You UK amazing hey youtubers
is charlie new Justice League footage
let's break it down we get to see Jason
Momoa in full battle gear just going
crazy if you're wondering what the
hell's going on while this awesome
footage is dropping from all these
different that you know Marvel and DC
it's New York Comic Con right now so
I'll explain more about that at the end
of this but what you're looking at here
is them filming the Justice League
comic-con footage along with some other
stuff too like they've added a bunch of
new stuff like Batman wearing the new
version of his costume Ben Affleck said
there's two different versions of the
bat suit there's the one that you saw
during Batman V Superman like felt more
lightweight cloth looking version then
you have the more hardcore battle suit
that's a little less cranked up then the
Dark Knight Returns suit he was wearing
when he was fighting Superman that's
more like wearing the tank like you know
the difference between the tumbler in
the new version of the Batmobile which
also got upgrades for Justice League
although it's kind of hard to tell just
seeing them right next to each other
it's just that they're fighting
Steppenwolf parademons of course
everybody's gonna have to armor up way
more than they have been in the past so
a lot of this should seem familiar him
going to recruit Aquaman they
intersperse it with footage of them
playing with the cameras I'm kind of a
camera geek so this is all really
interesting to me like these are just as
fun for me as the actual straight-up
trailers with footage from the movie but
a lot of these cameras that they work
with are like hundreds of thousands of
dollars
sidenote there was a Frankenstein camera
rig that the director of thor ragnarok
posted just to give you an idea this is
five plus re cameras synced together for
like some big action set piece that's
gonna be happening in the Thor movie but
back to Justice League stuff the reason
why you see these Frankenstein cameras
is because they capture a lot of high
frame rate stuff the new thing now is to
capture 8k and even though we're like a
long time away from being able to see 8k
movies in our homes or on DVD or
anything like that it'll be here in the
next 10 years and what they do is they
shrink the image down so there's a lot
more color data there's a lot more
visual information on-screen than if you
were just shooting and say like
1080p or even 4k this kind of looks like
the ruins of Wayne Manor they kind of
explained that in the history of this
movie universe it's fallen into
disrepair and Batman Prix Batman vs
Superman is just too bummed out to try
and fix it but the whole idea is is that
Superman's sacrifice inspires him to
form the Justice League so I would
expect that you know sometime in the
future continuity maybe during the
Batman films you'll see him rebuilding
Wayne Manor bunch of green screen of
course is gonna be green screen so many
special effects in this movie
Aquaman and his full armor Jason Momoa
just mugging for camera he's probably
one of the most fun people to hang out
with on set but real-life Jason Momoa is
kind of like Shazam this little kid in
this huge person's body
Ezra Miller in the practical version of
the costume this is kind of like the way
they did Captain America Civil War
people wore suits on camera but then
later when they were doing the special
effects they digitally replaced a lot of
this stuff so a lot of the costumes when
you see him in the actual movie will be
mostly CG but they put the actors in
them on camera because it helps their
performance and it gives the people that
do special effects something to work
with this is the old lightweight suit
with him jumping here this reminds me of
like a super hardcore version of that
Flash Fight Club trailer but it looks
like they're writing the elevator down
into the Batcave just because of the
rock behind them they're up on the roof
of the Gotham City Police Department
with the bat-signal I know this kind of
looks like Superman in the black costume
but this is actually a stunt double for
Batman who's just using the grappling
hook to jump across this expanse here
Star Wars Death Star style although
technically I think that would be Wonder
Woman to swing Batman across carrying
him around like a tiny little baby
Batman recruiting the flash this is that
scene where he's like why are you
sitting in my chair dude but just stunts
flash getting kicked around probably by
something really huge Batman getting
lifted off the ground by someone in
Wayne Manor maybe one of the Justice
League members Wonder Woman and Aquaman
in full battle gear being the [ __ ] out
of someone Aquaman even has his Trident
they're the two most powerful people
besides Superman in the Justice League
Batman in the new bat suit like the
picture that Zack Snyder showed off in
the new
flyingbat cape the beauty of this is
that you can't tell if Wonder Woman is
destroying someone or cheering and
triumph Justice League assembled for
giant CG action set piece Aquaman baro
Wonder Woman's sword sure why not and
this is obviously the whole cast and
crew just waving you know thank you to
everybody goodbye because they finished
principal photography they still have
reshoots but this is a football stadium
for scenes that add context for cyborg
so cyborg in the comics before he
becomes cyborg is like this star athlete
football player then he gets into the
accident becomes cyborg so they'll
probably have some flashback scenes for
him here but really cool I really like
the way they're marketing this right now
just like showing people hey we're
making something it's gonna be really
awesome not waiting to like the very end
to just dump stuff like here just like a
little teaser for something really
awesome we're making they don't have to
spoil stuff they just have to like show
you something really cool every once in
a while just here's some breadcrumbs
just to tide you over till we have a
real trailer which is supposed to be
dropping around Christmas time this year
but what's gonna happen is is they'll do
reshoots later so we'll continue seeing
stuff from behind the scenes in addition
to actual trailers in the next six
months or so but this movie justice
league is coming out November next year
if you guys didn't know so it's not
gonna be around for at least another
year but just a reminder of all like all
the really big stuff that I'm working on
next there's a Justice Society legends
of tomorrow four night crossover trailer
they just posted so I'll do a video for
that next there's an iron fist
Netflix panel that's happening at New
York Comic Con tomorrow they're dropping
a new trailer so obviously I'll do
videos for that there's a Punisher panel
like a Jon Bernthal panel that's
happening on Sunday so Punisher stuff
this weekend to a whole bunch of Marvel
a whole bunch of DC so I'll be posting
updates on when stuff is coming on
Twitter and Facebook the links for that
are in the description but be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's got to
be awesome it's gonna be a really good
weekend so just the society legends of
tomorrow should post in a couple hours
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that last big crazy
flash trailer and you can click here for
the marvel defenders Netflix and chill
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight